hey this is Z for geek culture we're
here at the xbox III
2017 media showcase let's go inside and
check out what it's all about
influencer check ins because I'm always
under the influence wait what is that
over there that sounds like the hum of a
911 GT Porsche
of course over here we have a Forza
Motorsport 7 and this is where they
debut that lovely car yesterday at the
media showcase and this is like the
deluxe edition not that collector's
edition for 500 this is probably like
five thousand to build this entire rig
but once you got it you're like a pro at
it then they got some swag over here on
the Left
got minecraft you got Forza Halo that's
a must-have at Xbox
Gears of War and
this is where all the magic happens
inside the Galen Center this is actually
where USC plays their games for
volleyball and basketball but now it's
been turned into
the mecca of video games
which is kind of ironic because now you
have the jock Stadium being taken over
by a bunch of nerds playing video games
and look at this is magic
[Music]
of course no gaming event can be done
without the dipping sauce of the orders
thank you very much good sir beautiful
gentleman with beautiful beards
serving up delicious food
more food porn over here you can see
they have the mirrors the cast light on
them crispy wonton
hey it's Alicia all right behind us
are the head honcho of e culture trying
to get her to rub on two
nice little assorted mini fruit tarts
again look at that mirror
over here is where they give coffee
to all these media partners and now I
have a mini javelin
and this is where you get the latest
demos of the games a lot of these are
the first party published games for
Microsoft and sells Super Lucky's tale
we've got Halo Wars dude someone
actually brought their keyboard down is
this on Windows 10
superior gaming
then we got that crack back crackdown 3
oh
sorry
Assassin's Creed original air the
Brotherhood was invented
probably the most hyped games out of
everything out here
Russian models
watch out for Trump he has a thing for
them
see sports from see of these
now those are the dream right here
drinks and video games and comfortable
chairs see sports maybe that's where
we're going
over here is where
they have deconstructed the Xbox 1x torn
it apart you can see all of the inner
hardware and my coat rips and the
battery we've got a cooling fan over
there and when you smash it all together
of course you get this this is the bad
boy of them all what we've all been
waiting for almost a year now since they
announced project Scorpio finally
revealed yesterday and call the Xbox one
X is the tongue twister but if you
practice enough you can get it
and this is something that they tore out
of the pages of the Nike ID
this is the Xbox design lab no
coincidence that Nike also has a Nike
lab but you can design your own custom
controller with as many color
combinations as humanly possible so
you have one that's made at e3 2017 this
is numbered individually numbered 3 of
1000 so you can make it on the computer
they're
super sick and I think you can pay for
it here and
receive it later so cool customisation
joints again more games and more chicken
skewers
minecraft mean crap they even have the
razor colored one
how do you like those 8-bit models in
true 4k fidelity
well what happened here shoes here what
happened they evaporated it's like
Cinderella and it's a near midnight yeah
basically except it's totally non
nevermind
more video games ending of course with
the Forza
I'm gonna go actually get a drink right
now
and the assortment of drinks
because influences got to be under the
influence
what's going to grab water actually
not dude is double-fisting
so there you have it this is the e3 Xbox
2017 showcase and is a celebration of
the dominance incoming dominance of Xbox
in these console wars are looking
forward to it of course it sells good
things for the consumers but what a way
to treat the media today here at media
day